the Trump administration is working with
States to step up coronavirus testing it
comes as Democrats in Congress and on
the campaign trail say the president is
downplaying the threat of a widespread
outbreak that could [ __ ] the country
and its economy correspondent Steve
Dorsey is live at the White House with
more good morning Steve
good morning the president sent out
mixed messages at a rally in South
Carolina last night he gave a glowing
review of his administration's response
just after dismissing the coronavirus as
a hoax and accusing Democrats of
politicizing it this is that new hoax
but you know we did something that's
been pretty amazing president Trump says
he's optimistic the US will contain the
virus people are getting better almost
everybody that we see is getting better
but the president's confidence comes
amid a whistleblower complaint alleging
federal health workers lacked proper
training and protective equipment while
processing Americans at two California
air bases after they returned from
coronavirus hotspots in Asia and then
released I am concerned that I'm hearing
from this whistleblowers report that
that certain procedures might not have
been followed Democratic presidential
frontrunner senator Bernie Sanders told
supporters in South Carolina the
president is unprepared to protect the
country start worrying about the corona
virus and the health care crisis in
America do your job as president joe
biden accused the president of silencing
his top public health experts it's bad
enough that we have a president can't
tell the truth we now the president
won't let other people tell the truth
and in a 60 Minutes interview michael
bloomberg piled on Donald Trump fired
the pandemic staff that was in the
federal government to deal with this two
years ago and so we have nobody there
the president has put new pressure on
the Fed to cut interest rates in
response to the outbreak as chairman
Jerome Powell promises to use the feds
quote tool
to support the economy Dina all right
Steve thank you